[Musica]
Chi conosce questo quadro alzi la mano
questo dipinto si intitola paesaggio con
la caduta di Icaro Ma dov'è Icaro lo
vedete il figlio di Dedalo
Icaro in fondo sulla destra del quadro
vedete le gambe che spuntano dall'acqua
e quello che amo di questo quadro e che
l'elemento centrale Icaro non salta
subito agli occhi e se notate anche le
persone che si muovono all'interno di
questo dipinto sembrano non notare il
fatto straordinario che sta accadendo
sotto i loro occhi un uomo che è caduto
dal cielo e precipita in mare
anche l'obesità
a qualcosa che sotto i nostri occhi
tutti i giorni
Ma che spesso non vediamo o magari lo
vediamo ma non è percepiamo la
drammaticità
e parlo dello Stigma
nonostante la comunità scientifica sia
Concorde nel ritenere l'obesità una
malattia una malattia cronica una
malattia complessa una malattia
recidivante una malattia multifattoriale
data dall'interazione di fattori
genetici di fattori ambientali di
fattori
psicologici e opinione comune che il
peso sia qualcosa sotto la propria
responsabilità e che con la forza di
volontà e l'impegno ogni persona può
ottenere i cali di peso desiderati e
raggiungere le forme corporee desiderate
e quindi l'obesità non è vista come una
malattia ma come una scelta come una
colpa come risultato di un fallimento
personale come
la il fatto che la persona non tiene
molto a se stessa perché appunto se ci
mettesse la forza di volontà riuscirebbe
a ottenere i cali di peso e le forme
corporee
desiderate e a volte per qualcuno la
soluzione l'obesità è semplice Magari è
qualcosa di cui avete sentito parlare
anche voi
Basta che mangi di meno e ti muovi di
più Hai risolto il problema e sarebbe
come andare da una persona affetta da
depressione e dirgli ho trovato la cura
per te
Basta che sorridi di più e sei meno
triste ma in realtà la questione è molto
più complessa Ma questa visione negativa
dell'obesità questa visione
semplicistica
dell'obesità porta le persone affette da
questa condizione a sperimentare spesso
denigrazione discriminazione
discriminazione e una svalutazione
sociale e porta le persone affette da
obesità essere bersaglio di numerosi
stereotipi negativi che le vedono come
persone pigre come persone goffe come
persone golose come persone che non
hanno forza di volontà
e l'obesità non una malattia ma una
colpa una scelta Quanti di voi possono
aver avuto questi pensieri
Non preoccupatevi se anche voi li avete
perché questi atteggiamenti negativi
sono comuni sono diffusi a livello
globale
sono Sfortunatamente in aumento sono
difficili da modificare e sono
socialmente accettati
e quindi è normale fare dell'ironia sul
peso
spesso però c'è anche chi è convinto che
essere duri stigmatizzare possa motivare
le persone a rendersi conto della
propria situazione a cambiare
ma in realtà è proprio vero il contrario
e la ricerca ha dimostrato come lo
stigma sul peso posso aumentare la
vulnerabilità a depressione ansia
un'immagine corporea negativa
possa portare a isolamento solitudine un
senso di sentirsi inautabili
di sentirsi senza speranza e nei giovani
soprattutto anche a pensieri e atti di
suicidio e a volte la risposta allo
stigma la risposta emotiva subire stigma
porta le persone per esempio a evitare
l'attività fisica
a evitare le visite mediche porta le
persone a rispondere allo stigma
mangiando più cibo
e questo come potete ben capire diventa
un grand ostacolo alla gestione del peso
e alla salute fisica e psicologica della
persona e a causa del peso le persone
affette da obesità possono subire
penalizzazioni nelle aree più importanti
della loro vita per esempio nel lavoro
si è visto come un candidato affetto da
obesità ha meno probabilità di essere
assunto rispetto a un candidato
normopeso nonostante abbiano un uguale
curriculum si è visto come la persona
affetta da obesità soprattutto le donne
possono guadagnare di meno rispetto alla
controparte normopeso ottenere meno
promozione ottenere meno incarichi di
prestigio anche l'istruzione la scuola è
un luogo dove spesso il bambino affetto
da obesità per la prima volta sperimenta
lo stigma e a volte questo stigma lo
accompagna più lungo tutto il corso
degli studi gli atteggiamenti negativi
sono stati ritrovati anche negli
insegnanti nei coetanei nei compagni
negli insegnanti di educazione fisica
a livello relazionale Quante storie mi
vengono raccontate di bullismo di prese
in giro di umiliazioni di rifiuti e
quando noi subiamo un rifiuto il nostro
cervello Attiva le stesse aree del
dolore fisico
e quante persone per paura di essere
rifiutata e mi dicono mi sono ritirato
ho ritirato O quante persone non vivono
cose che gli piacciono per la paura del
giudizio dottore Io amo nuotare ma non
vado in piscina
per alcuni è difficile anche salire su
un autobus
ci starò in quel posto cosa penserà la
gente
alcune persone trovano difficile
camminare in un parco per paura di
essere guardati per paura di essere
additati
o magari la chiamiamo pigrizia non ha
voglia di fare
quando magari domani Guardate la TV un
telefilm i cartoni animati Provate a
notare come spesso e questa è un'altra
fonte di Stigma le persone affette da
obesità sono rappresentate in ruoli
stereotipati
ridicolizzati e ruoli negativi pensiamo
a dare delle coseno di Harry Potter
anche come viene presentato nel libro Un
bambino obeso bambino egoista un bambino
capriccioso un bambino Bullo nei
confronti del grande
provate a guardare le notizie che
parlano dell'obesità Provate a digitare
obesità su qualsiasi motore di ricerca e
le immagini che appaiono non tutte
Fortunatamente Ma molte sono queste
immagini che alimentano l'idea della
persona golosa della persona pigra e
Come vedete non c'è distinzione tra
adulti e bambini che vengono
rappresentati che mangiano grandi
quantità di cibo spazzatura stravaccati
sul divano e spesso troviamo immagini
questo purtroppo avviene Anche in alcuni
convegni medici di parte del corpo
glutei addomi cosce che disumanizzano la
persona affetta da obesità disumanizzano
la malattia
e noi medici noi professionisti della
Salute Purtroppo anche noi non siamo
immuni
da questa da questi atteggiamenti
negativi verso l'obesità sono stati
ritrovati in tutte le figure
professionali medici infermieri dietiste
psicologi e questo
può portare
a un indebolimento dell'Alleanza
terapeutica può portare il medico a
dedicare meno tempo ad avere meno
fiducia nel suo paziente ad avere meno
pazienza
dall'altra parte può portare il paziente
ma non avere fiducia nel sistema
sanitario a rifiutare le cure
o magari a trovare metodi alternativi
dannosi che diventano un vero attentato
al proprio corpo
e un altro tipo di Stigma
nell'ambiente medico e che per l'obesità
non sono offerti gli stessi livelli di
cura che sono offerti per altre
condizioni croniche
Ma uno degli effetti più dannosi dello
stigma del peso e la sua
interiorizzazione Cos'è lo stigma
interiorizzato che la stessa persona
affetta da obesità
Pensa che tutti gli stereotipi che
abbiamo visto prima siano veri e quando
il privilegio di poter insegnare ai
futuri psicoterapeuti la psicologia
l'approccio psicologico al paziente
affetto da obesità di sempre quando
entrerà nella vostra stanza il paziente
affetto da obesità preparate due sedie
in più perché spesso si porta con sé una
grande vergogna e una grande autocritica
dottore
guardi Non so neanche perché sono qua io
sono un fallimento dottore so che la
deluderò deluderò anche lei ho deluso
tutti nella mia vita so che è colpa mia
E penso che non ci sia niente
di più triste per un professionista
della Salute vedere una persona che già
fa fatica perché non è facile chiedere
aiuto e che si colpevolizza se ritiene
responsabile della sua condizione e
parla di sé come un fallimento come
qualcuno che lì a farti perdere tempo
Ecco perché spesso
quella persona affetta da obesità un
grande lavoro è quello di evitare che
sprofondi nelle paludi della colpa
e le paludi dell'autocritica
Purtroppo nel nostro lavoro c'è un altro
tasso di
abbandono della terapia da parte delle
persone affette da obesità è un nostro
grande compito è quello di evitare che
sprofondino nelle paludi della tristezza
Cosa possiamo fare intanto
un lavoro di squadra
dove partecipi il mondo politico il
mondo medico l'opinione pubblica
soprattutto dove partecipi anche il
paziente
la sua voce la sua storia i suoi bisogni
le sue esperienze nessuno
in questo gioco di squadra deve rimanere
indietro
Bisogna dire no allo stigma sul peso
e bisogna ricordarsi che bisogna
combattere l'obesità ma non le persone
affette da obesità
e penso che adesso tutti vediate Icaro
né Cogliate la potenza e spero che da
stasera anche possiate vedere meglio lo
stigma sul peso perché il primo passo
per ridurre lo stigma sul peso e
riconoscerne la sua presenza grazie
[Applauso]